كانت الخطه اشبهوا بوضع قنبله ذريه على
الارض في طوكيو واخبار اليابانيين باننا
سنقوم بتفجيرها هكذا يرى مصدر حضر هذه
الاجتماعات خطه
لجات فيها واشنطن للدنمارك والسويد
والنرويج الاخيره تحديدا كانت الاهم لاكثر
من سبب الولايات المتحده وسعت بشكل كبير
خلال السنوات التي سبقت الحرب تواجدها في
النرويج بما في ذلك قاعده غواصات جددت
مؤخرا المحاره والغواصون النرويجيون لديهم
خبره في التنقيب عن النفط والغاز في اعماق
البحار ويمكن ايضا الوثوق بهم للحفاظ على
سريه المهمه سبب اخر وهو ان المتفجرات
كانت بحاجه للتمويه بطريقه تجعلها تظهر
لتقنيات المراقبه الروسيه كجزء من الطبيعه
والنرويج هنا لديها الامكانيات التقنيه
لذلك جزء اخر مهم وهو المنفعه المتبادله
النرويج قد تستفيد بان تكون محطه بديله
للغاز الروسي الى اوروبا وبالمناسبه
تزامنت التفجيرات مع افتتاح بولندا
والنرويج لخطي انابيب البلطيق ينقل الغاز
النرويجي من بحر الشمال الى اوروبا عبر
الدنمارك امريكا هي الاخرى قد تستفيد
بكونها بديلا اخر في 2022 زادت الصادرات
الامريكيه من الغاز المسال لاوروبا
بالنسبه 137 في المئه مقارنه بالفين 2021
لكن امرا مهما اخر يخص النرويج هو ان
اوسلو كان لديها الاجابه على سؤال مهم متى
تجرى العمليه الاجابه النموذجيه كانت في
موعد ثابت منذ 21 عاما تدريبات في بحر
البلطيق غطاء مثالي لزرع المتفجرات
[موسيقى]